well less than 24 hours after we here at
the score esports drop tower explainer
video on the tee food vs. faze clan
lawsuit here we are again with more
drama more rumors and more facts to
clear up
[Music]
ok guys yesterday we did publish a video
on the tee foo vs faze clan lawsuit
trying to cut through all the drama all
the rumors and all the misunderstood
miscellaneous facts that aren't facts
and if you haven't seen that video I
highly recommend you check it out you're
gonna need a strong grounding in this
whole issue to understand what we're
gonna go through here so what's changed
well I really did not expect to be
sitting here in front of you talking
about this issue as soon as I am but as
we were putting that video out and later
into the night a couple new bombshells
dropped namely the alleged gamer
agreement the contract that teef who
signed with faze clan was leaked to the
public later that same night faze clan
released a completely new statement this
time in audio format and it was 7
minutes long so there's plenty to go
over let's start though with the alleged
gamer agreement now just a note before
we begin this section this alleged
contract was leaked by a website called
the blast calm which is a celebrity news
site now it's worth noting here that the
score eSports has not to this point
independently verified the authenticity
of this alleged contract now we're not
gonna pour over every detail of this
contract but the main facts and figures
that a lot of people have been debating
about and frankly misunderstanding out
there are the compensation numbers for T
foo under this alleged original contract
so let's go through those and compare
them to what the earlier lawsuit alleged
and what faze clan atif who have been
saying thus far firstly under the
original contract T foo again allegedly
was entitled to two thousand dollars per
month in salary
now that salary could increase up to 25%
or decrease by 25% as a result of a
performance review of sorts now for
those of you who aren't so good at math
at home two thousand dollars a month is
obviously $24,000 per year which I think
we'd both agree for the world's arguably
top gamer is not
exactly adequate compensation and yeah I
don't think it's that contentious to say
tifu is the top gamer in the world sorry
new master 69 revenue garnered from
in-game merchandise would be allegedly
split 50-50 between tee foo and face
claim now in our original video I made
great pains to clarify the 80/20 split
number as it pertained to third-party
endorsements there was a lot of
misunderstanding a few days ago about
that online and I hope we helped clear
some of that up now this contract
confirms if it is authentic what the
lawsuit alleges which is that if faze
clan brings tee foo a third-party
endorsement
they faze clan are entitled to 80% of
the revenue from that endorsement and T
foo would take 20 now if T foo were to
bring an endorsement deal to faze clan
and if faze clan were to accept it
because of course they have veto powers
over that that deal would be split 50-50
any appearance or live touring money
that T foo would get would likewise be
split 50/50 for him and face claim now
you may remember if you watched our
previous video or god bless you if you
actually read the T through lawsuit that
it contends that faze clan is acting
illegally as a talent agency in the
state of California well in this alleged
original t fook contract it does state
that the parties submit exclusively to
the state or federal courts located in
new york new york you will also recall
that faze clans initial twitter
statement on this whole matter is hey we
took 0 of his twitter money 0 of his
youtube money 0 of his streaming money
we only took 60 thousand dollars from
the guy we had the right to exercise
this 80/20 thing and we waived it well
as the contract notes and as should be
obvious to all of us failure of a party
to enforce its rights will not be
construed as a waiver of such rights in
other words just because faze clan
decided not to take their 80/20 split in
past instances doesn't mean for the
remainder of t Fu's two-year contract
that they can't just do it anytime they
want I don't wanna get too sidetracked
here but there's also closets as he gets
three weeks vacation which is pretty
funny it's the same vacation as me now
here's where the contract gets really
interesting and the stuff about
retaining T food for faze clan in the
future even if his contract were to run
its natural course comes up upon lawful
termination of his offer upon
termination of this contract after it
all runs out he would be obliged for
three months after to provide faze clan
with any offers from other companies and
provide them with the identity of those
companies and have faze clan be able to
match those offers within 15 days if
faze clan were able and willing to match
those third party offers he would be
obliged to take them basically what this
means is if T Fu's contract runs its
natural course even if he waits a couple
months after let's say optic gaming or
some other competitor comes to him and
wants to sign him he is obliged to
provide that offer to faze clan and faze
clan could say yeah you know what we can
match this exactly or do better so
you're still on faze clan too bad next
comes a clause that I found particularly
shocking I've never drafted a contract
or a gaymer agreement for anyone but I
probably wouldn't put this in if I did
if T foo failed to fulfill his duties
for faze clan in any way or he made
disparaging remarks against the company
or he basically ran afoul of them in any
way outlined in this contract faze clan
in this alleged contract contends that
they can prohibit tea fruit from playing
video games publicly they state online
or in live tournaments or professionally
for a period of six months effective
directly after his termination they're
literally saying that if they decided to
for lack of a better word buy ot foo he
couldn't play video games if anyone was
watching within six months this is also
another thing that the original lawsuit
from T foo filed earlier this week
alleges is illegal
there's also another key point in this
contract that notes that T Fu's content
created under the faze clan brand while
he's signed to faze clan belongs to faze
clans in perpetuity now what does that
actually mean well I'm sitting here in
front of you doing this video but this
video belongs to the score eSports and
when and if I do leave the score eSports
it will still belong to the score
eSports and if that all sounds really
crazy to you I completely understand
however just to contextualise it that
and the non-compete clause in other
forms are pretty
standard when it comes to content
creators working for larger corporations
one general observation I had about this
contract while reading it and it is
supported by a lot of the things that
faze clan actually said was that it was
clearly drafted for someone who doesn't
do tea whose job there's a lot of talk
of practices and team captains and
attending LAN events and where prize
money goes it's clearly oriented around
professional eSports players Cod players
csgo players probably at some point faze
clan thought that fortnight was gonna go
war in a competitive format but it
didn't turn out to be the case and T foo
is more of an entertainer he's more of a
content creator than a competitive
player so a lot of the language in this
contract seems woefully inappropriate
for what he actually does okay that was
the complicated part and reading that
contract was legit more difficult than
reading the lawsuit the highlighter got
to work out on that one now let's move
along to faze clans response later the
same day late at night that the alleged
contract was leaked faze clan posted
their biggest most robust response to
this whole controversy to date this is a
video that absolutely no one at faze
clan ever wanted to make because it's
going to shed some negative light on a
guy that we care a lot about but he's
forced this upon us and this isn't the
way we would like to publicly conduct
our business people want these things to
be public than they will
it was a voice video post that was seven
minutes long featuring the voices of Lee
trink he's a co-owner and CEO of faze
clan and face seabass so I just finished
saying how the contract seemed pretty
inappropriate for what T who actually
does well phase C bass notes in the
audio video response that that original
contract was drawn up under different
management and is outdated he also says
that phase clans current new management
decided that the contract was
inappropriate and not good way before T
foo actually sent the letters from the
lawyers trying to terminate his contract
now according to C pass multiple
renegotiation attempts were made from
September of last year and possibly even
prior all the way up to maybe a few
weeks ago these alleged contract reworks
according to sea bass included such
incentives as seven-figure salaries
that's a little better
the two grand a month no splits in
income whatsoever and no splits in
revenue no 8020 no fifty-fifty just one
hundred zero forty fou some of you guys
expressed concerns that Bayes clan might
have been skimming off T foo support a
creator code well see bass does take
great pains to say that that's just not
true they never touch it they never took
any money from it now after allegedly
presenting T foo and his camp with offer
after offer that got better and better
and better and more in favor of T foo
they see bass alleges that communication
completely broke down the offers were
refused and eventually they were just
met with silence although even so he
notes that no one in faze clan was aware
of a pending lawsuit and it hit them all
by complete surprise which echoes face
banks his earlier comments on Twitter
now trink one of the co-owners of faze
clan sort of reiterates and goes into
more detail but what seabass said about
the contracts they presented him and how
lucrative they were and how good the
splits were and how they improved each
time he also contends that Tipu had
signed contracts like this before and he
knew what he was getting into when he
originally signed it and it started back
in April of 2018 now during this whole
time when T foo was getting new offers
from faze clan and refusing them or
being silent obviously the original
contract still stood and everything in
it still stood but as you guys already
know from reading previous faze clan
statements they declined to exercise
their rights on a lot of those splits
they didn't collect almost any money
from him except for that sixty thousand
dollar figure now Lee trink says of that
quote we made the decision not to
collect any money under the old
agreement except for quote a couple of
brand deals that's where that sixty
thousand comes from and they only took
20% of that when it came to phase versus
T foo now you'll remember when we went
over the contract that allegedly they
were entitled base clan were entitled to
80% and they only took 20 probably a
goodwill measure to show T foo that he
was valued in the company and that even
though he hadn't accepted the new offers
that they were willing to honor them he
goes on to say quote the relationship
with T foo was much more important than
money
end quote now this echos exactly what we
said in our
video do not get bogged down by the
80/20 splits the $60,000 figure again
the emotional tweets this isn't about
what faze clan can directly rake off of
Tipu in dollar value a lot of it is in
intangibles in the power that comes with
saying T Fu's on our team we have T foe
on our on our brand and we can sell
towards that we can do a deal with the
Pepsi's of the coax or the Sony's of the
world because we've got T foo on our
roster even if they're not making a
dollar off of his prize money or his
twitch sub money Li drink does also at
red state that T Fu's brother
alleges that t fo wants to start his own
eSports organization which again we
talked about in our last video and is
really no surprise here T foo doesn't
want to get out of faze clan just to
keep being T foo he wants T foo to
become a brand the new faze clan bigger
than faze clan drink finally makes an
analogy to basketball saying that's like
the Lakers leg LeBron James create a
competing NBA team
they would never let that happen and we
should never let that happen end quote
it's pretty reasonable coming from faze
clan obviously so as we painstakingly
went over and you guys can read the
alleged contract for yourselves it is
not a good document however again
according to faze claim just to
summarize they presented him with many
counter offers that got better and
better and better and more lucrative and
he declined them making it clear that T
foo no longer wants to be a part of
phase no matter what the money
looks like phase conversely obviously
does not want to let him go not only
because he's a huge asset to their brand
but they don't want to create their next
big competitor no doubt war will come
out in the following days regarding this
lawsuit and different responses will be
fired back and forth maybe new contracts
will be leaked but I think at this point
a lot of you are kind of ready to make
your decisions I saw some comments in
our last video along the lines of I
don't know who to unsub to I don't know
whose side I should be on and I
completely understand that and I can't
help you with it because at the end of
the day it's a moral ethical compass
kind of decision T foo is a victim of
his own success you have to decide
whether you think he should abide by a
contract which is at this point not
really appropriate for him even though
he signed it when it was or if you side
with T foo and you think that
cuz of his own success because his wings
are spreading he should be able to break
away from faze clan completely thanks
for watching if you want more content
like this hit the sub button and ring
that notification bell for unique
bite-sized videos you will find anywhere
else hit up our Instagram Twitter and
Facebook pages
[Music]